Michael welcome how can I help you well  if I'm going to save fake Eleanor I need  some help negotiating I don't even know  what to offer I mean what do you get  somebody who wants to eat a unicorn a  unicorn  bib yes no no unicorn holders you know  like like corn holders but for unicorns  perhaps if we just move away from the  unicorn thing all together anyway  there's a bigger problem the bad place  crew they're all terrible bullies and  they outnumber me they even have their  own bad Janet I'll show you bad Janet  what bad Janet where is the nearest cafe  oh um that's a good question it's up  your mom's butt you fat dink  even the Pacific Janet who behaves in  such a manner unclear but the point is I  never have to deal with negative emotion  of any sort I could use some backup too  honey  Oh Michael of course why don't you just  bring them all here Shirley this  magnificent house will placate them Oh  perfect perfect I'll be right back  you